now good evening thanks for staying with
us at 6 30. i'm denise feldas and i'm
bryan loftis summertime right around the
corner is valley schools wrapping up for
the year most this week ccsd finishing
school on wednesday that means
graduation getting underway and that has
led to some controversy for students
christian casares is joining us now in
studio with more on this apparent issue
christian well guys we're talking about
two seniors at rancho high school that
they say the ceremony dress code for
their school is unfair both are looking
to show off their culture and their
identity during their big moment on
stage but ccsd's policy says otherwise
so allow students to walk with pride and
represent what has helped guide them up
until this moment marisol rodriguez is
about to finish high school in the next
few days she wants to wear her green
stall which represents her latino roots
for ashley garcia representation on
graduation day is important graduation
dress code currently deprives me of the
right to graduate with this sole along
with the pin of the quetzal both seniors
addressing their concerns during the
last clark county school district
meeting during public comment hoping for
change instead the superintendent saying
it's up to each school to make such
decision our vantage point there are
certainly constitutional issues but at a
broader level it just seems like a
silly thing for the schools to be
focused on atar hashibula with the aclu
of nevada says first amendment rights
don't stop at students and ccsd needs to
have a district-wide policy in place
it's unclear to us what problem they're
attempting to solve by restricting the
use of accessories how is that harmful
to students right to get an education
they've already completed their
requirements rancho high school issuing
this email saying graduates
participating in the graduation ceremony
who wish to wear stolts cords or
medallions representing their cultural
heritage that have not been earned by
rancho high school district programs
clubs activities must bring those items
for specific approval to the graduation
rehearsal students shall now be battling
an unjust dress code weeks before their
final moment of glory
well the aclu of nevada says they plan
to speak with ccsd very soon to
establish a fair policy for both
students and the school district
christian gossip is live local now